dans l'actualité ce soir l' enquête sur
la collision en haute savoie le
chauffeur du car scolaire placée en
garde à vue et interrogé par la police
depuis la fin de la matinée une marche
silencieuse s'est déroulée à thonon en
hommage aux sept collégiens tuer le coup
d'éclat du président sénégalais
abdoulaye wade au sommet sur
l'alimentation à rome ils accusent la
fao de traiter les pays pauvres comme
des mendiants les participants veulent
relancer l'agriculture vivrière le
virage d'un géant mondial de
l'automobile l'américain general motors
se convertit à la voiture écologique
l'effondrement des ventes des gros
véhicules entraîne la fermeture de
quatre usines en france l'assemblée
adopté en première lecture la réforme
des institutions la gauche a voté contre
le sénat puis le congrès doivent
maintenant se prononcer du périphérique
à la campagne dans ce journal l'histoire
d'un couple sans domicile qui s'en est
sorti après quatre ans au bord du
périphérique parisien
il vient d'emménager dans une maison
c'est le dossier de cette émission
enfin les chiffres du bac 2008 il y aura
6 115 mille candidats cette année c'est
moins que l'an dernier
le doyen 63 ans le plus jeune 13 en
reportage à la fin de ce journal avec
l'un des benjamins de l'épreuve bonsoir
et bienvenue à tous que s'est il passé
exactement sur le passage à niveau
d'allinges en haute savoie
hier on ne le sait pas encore avec
précision et la police cherche à
comprendre car les versions divergent
on va y venir dans un instant d'abord
l'hommage l'hommage de toute une
agglomération aux victimes
trois filles et quatre garçons de 13 à
14 ans franck genauzeau damien louvet
sur place
soudés dans la douleur les familles des
victimes se pressent devant la chapelle
ardente
certaines sont revenus plusieurs fois
dans la nuit
elle avait du mal à y croire à
l'intérieur les corps de six des sept
adolescents décédés au petit matin sur
le parvis de l'église
les larmes n'ont pas séché ils m'ont
enlevé mon gars qu'on pût retour que
tout le monde y voilà maintenant je sais
pas quoi faire c'est de remonter la
pente puis faire ce qu'il a à faire pour
la justice qui fasse son travail puis
bon ben voilà pourquoi que c'est arrivé
à ce moment là pour mon fils pour nos
enfants qui sont dans le circle dans
cette petite ville de 4000 habitants
certains anonymes se sont aussi déplacés
pour soutenir les familles
moi ça m'a bouleversé
c'est normal qu'il vienne moi qui
connaissent ce village qui est toujours
très très gai le village et refermer
très triste très très consternés
impuissant vous devrez aider dans le
courant de la matinée le président de la
république nicolas sarkozy se présente
devant l'église à l'abri des regards il
tente de réconforter les familles et
promet de les tenir informés rapidement
d avance l enquête
quelques minutes plus tard le ministre
de l'éducation xavier darcos se rend
dans le collège meurtri une minute de
silence est respectée
pleine d'émotion
en france des parents d'élèves sont
encore sous le choc sans mal c'est sûr
parce que bon ben j'ai on pense beaucoup
aux familles donc on imagine leur
imagine pas trop de ce qui va ressentir
les petites communes et c'est vrai qu'on
est tous touchés par un voisin disparu
on a besoin d'être tous ensemble on a
besoin d'en parler c'est sûr on connaît
les enfants enfin bon personnellement je
connais trois sur sept donc si quand
même énorme dans l'après midi à quelques
kilomètres de là d'autres lycéens et
collégiens se sont réunis spontanément
et en silence dans les rues de thonon
les bains
ils étaient 500 une fleur rouge dans les
cheveux en signe de compassion
au même moment les corps de six des sept
adolescents étaient sortis l'un après
l'autre le parvis de l'église était
alors désert comme si le village n'avait
pas voulu assister au départ de ses
enfants
ils seront inhumés jeudi après une
cérémonie dans l'enceinte du collège
près de 3000 personnes sont attendues
pour ce dernier hommage et on en vient à
lenquête alors je vous le disais le
chauffeur du car est entendue sous le
régime de la garde à vue depuis une
dizaine d'heures maintenant et
apparemment sa version n'est pas la même
que celle des premiers témoins sur place
benoit gadret thierry simonet
vingt-quatre heures après l'accident
l'autobus a été retiré des voix pour
être placé sous scellés épilogue d'une
longue journée d'investigation pour les
experts de la gendarmerie le moindre
objet le moindre indice tout a été
relevée la scène du drame modélisé en
trois dimensions l'équivalent de la
boîte noire du train prélever autant
d'éléments matériels pour tenter
d'écrire le scénario du drame
sur la petite route le bus a donc
emprunté le passage à niveau
mais la deuxième barrière s'est abaissée
d'ici le mans les gens devant on dit que
le quart avait su d'avancer de reculer
et que sa maman fait pas s'ils étaient
bloqués ne pouvait plus rien faire
bloqués sur les voies le car était
percutée à l'arrière tuant sur le coup
plusieurs enfants un enseignant et
plusieurs élèves assurent que le train
était pourtant annoncée
ce qui clignotaient et il a calé sur la
sur la voie puis donc à tous les profs
qui nous ont dit d'aller devant et après
de puissantes
le chauffeur exerce depuis 20 ans un
homme consciencieux et prudent affirme
son employeur qui l'a rencontrée juste
après l'accident
d'après lui il n'a pas franchi le
passage à niveau alors que les feux
étaient allumés
c'est à dire qu'il s'est engagé au
niveau du passage à niveau
normalement voilà au delà il n'a pas pu
m'expliquer ce qui s'est passé le
chauffeur est toujours ce soir en garde
à vue 25 témoins ont d'ores et déjà été
auditionné par les enquêteurs
et puis je vous propose d'écouter un
autre témoignage nos envoyés spéciaux
ont pu rencontrer l'une des enseignantes
qui était dans l'autocar en écoute un
choc terrible alors là bon nous on est
percutée et puis surtout c'est à la
descente du car quand on a réussi à
dégager enfin sortir les enfants et
qu'on a vu l'état du car enfin c'est
inimaginable
inimaginable l'arrière du chaos est
terme aux petits partis
le taux a été invoquée partie aussi
c'est affreux
on n'imaginait pas on a encore pas mal
d'enfants avec nous donc on n'imaginait
pas qu'il y ait eu autant de victimes
vraiment c'était c'est après après quand
on est allé faire un petit peu le bilan
et qu'on a conduit les enfants à terre
vous voyez kentucky qui s'en sortirait
pas d'eau il avait un qui était
incarcéré qui le toit a été ouvert dans
son thé qu'il était on n'arrivait pas à
se dégager
c'est horrible c'est horrible on l'a
indiqué dès hier des dizaines de
passages à niveau sont considérés comme
à risque et doit faire l'objet de
travaux en france nous avons voulu
savoir ce qu'il en était sur un site
bien précis port sainte foy en dordogne
il ya dix ans un accident avait fait 13
morts là bas
reportage francis mazoyer philippe dumas
y voilà voilà l'ancien la maison du
passage à niveau telles qu'elles étaient
par le passé c'était sa maison
heureusement il n'y avait personne à
l'intérieur
11h52 le 8 septembre 97 un camion rempli
de fioul force le passage à niveau de
port sainte foy réputé très dangereux
il percute un train régional lancé à 60
kilomètres/heure la citerne explose 13
morts dans les wagons de tête 68 blessés
il a fallu attendre six ans après la
catastrophe pour voir ce passage à
niveau supprimés c'est malheureux qu'il
faille une à une tragédie humaine de
cette ampleur pour prendre conscience
qu'il faut à faire quelque chose à tout
prix avant le drame de 1997 plusieurs
accidents dont cinq mortels s'était déjà
produit au même endroit en 2003 ce pont
a définitivement remplacé le passage à
niveau dangereux
l'aboutissement d'un projet très coûteux
la suppression d'un passage de niveau 10
préoccupant oscille entre 3 millions et
100 millions d'euros rff ne veut pas
assurée d'abord nous engageons 35
millions d'euros considérable
donc il nous faut les partenaires état
et collectivités locales doivent donc
mettre la main à la poche
l'objectif est la disparition totale des
passages à niveau dangereux
seulement voilà la france on compte
encore 340
selon réseau ferré de france seulement
10 peuvent être supprimés chaque année
la justice c'est sans doute le
dénouement dans ce qu'on appelle la
sphère de l'enfant du lac
on l'a appris en fin d'après-midi à l'ex
compagnon de la mère du garçon de 8 ans
sauvée de la noyade en vendée est passé
aux aveux
il a reconnu avoir tué la jeune femme et
tenté de supprimer son fils il doit être
mise en examen dans la soirée françois
privat alain darrigrand cédric horneck a
avoué le meurtre de son ex-compagne mais
aussi la tentative d'homicide sur le
petit antoine au lac d'apremont vendredi
dernier vers 4 heures du matin il l'a
conduit sur un ponton est au bord de
l'eau et de la peau c'est dans l'eau il
a maintenu la forme avec le bras pour
que la tête soit maintenue sous l'eau et
qu'il l'a maintenu ainsi jusqu'à ce que
l'enfant ne bougeait plus donc quand il
est reparti quand il a quitté les lieux
dans son esprit l'enfant était mort
auparavant c'est au domicile de son ex
petit ami qu'une violente dispute éclate
horneck pour plusieurs coups de poing au
visage de la jeune femme qui perd
connaissance
puis il l'étouffer avec un coussin il
explique il a du mal à expliquer il ne
savait plus ce qu'il faisait vraiment il
ne s'est pas rendu compte de lacs du
moins c'est ce qu'il me dit de ce qu'il
faisait également déféré cet après midi
une femme d'une quarantaine d'années qui
l'a hébergé durant sa courte cavale en
connaissance de cause
elles risquent trois années de prison
cédric horneck quant à lui encourt une
peine de réclusion à perpétuité
direction rome maintenant c'est là bas
que se tient le sommet de l'aef à eau
sur la pénurie alimentaire dans le monde
il a démarré sur les chapeaux de roue le
langage très feutré de la diplomatie a
été laissé de côté le président
sénégalais abdoulaye wade sans les prix
vous allez l'entendre avec virulence à
l'institution compte rendu et état des
lieux de la crise bernard lebrun karine
guillaume une cinquantaine de chefs
d'états 190 pays représentés
cela devait être une conférence et un
sommet ils sont venus au chevet de la
planète
toutes les cinq secondes un enfant meurt
de faim et il y à 860 millions de
personnes affamées sur la planète
un habitant sur six concernés désormais
même l'aide alimentaire est contingenté
folk ou de la nourriture a tellement
augmenté
il ya quelques années on pouvait remplir
cette passe maintenant on peut la rampe
hier qu'à 60%
autre conséquence le retour des émeutes
de la faim comme ici en egypte
elles ont pour origine le doublement du
prix du blé en moins de seize mois le
prix du riz lui aussi s'est envolé
denrées de base en haïti importés d'asie
son prix de vente a provoqué le premier
renversement d'un gouvernement
d'autres pays ont tremblé tous de
l'hémisphère sud et nourrir la planète
c'est tout l'enjeu de cette conférence
il faut donc aider les pays les plus
pauvres à se doter d'agriculture
modernes qui permettront leur suffisance
alimentaire un remède qui prendra du
temps
c'est pourquoi la france a doublé son
aide d'urgence offrant 100 millions de
dollars en clair de l'assistance
alimentaire du fou d'assystem en hongrie
le concept de foule assisting est
dépassé nous ne pouvons pas continuer à
être alimentaires comme des magnans je
l' ai déjà dit il faut dépasser cela
pour un pour assister l'agriculture
selon les projections en 2030 la planète
comptera 9 milliards d'habitants et pour
les nourrir selon la fh il faudra
multiplier par deux la production
alimentaire on avait même les pays
émergents les plus dynamiques sont
concernés par cette crise alimentaire
exemple l'inde
les taux de croissance à deux chiffres
ne suffisent pas à mettre fin à la
malnutrition correspondance arnauld
miguet arnaud le vert elles ont parcouru
des kilomètres pour confier leurs
enfants à cette équipe de médecins sans
frontières
dans ce village reclus de l'état du
bihar on ne voit pas des blouses
blanches tous les jours c'est même
rarissime
pourtant des problèmes il y en or ici
plus d'un tiers des enfants de moins de
cinq ans souffrent de sous-alimentation
c'est un cas de sévère malnutrition
cet enfant mesure 68 cm et ne passent
que saint cloud est normalement et sa
taille il devrait plutôt l'indifférence
pour endiguer ce fléau
sachez de pâtes nutritionnelle et
médicaments sont distribués les enfants
de ce village seront normalement tirer
d'affaires dans quelques semaines mais
il y en a tant d'autres car en inde la
malnutrition tue plus de 6000 petit
indien meurent chaque jour parce qu'ils
sont mal nous a mano quêta un enfant mal
nourri à un système immunitaire très
faibles donc des maladies beaucoup plus
facilement qu'un autre s'il y en a qui
ont des diarrhée ou de fortes fièvres
c'est comme un cercle vicieux une
maladie entraîne l'autre
rien fin et pauvreté ne sont pas
éradiquées en inde dans ce village on
vit avec moins de 1,1 euro par jour
cela ne connaissent pas les fruits d'une
croissance indienne à 9%
il sut des castes les plus basses ils
sont ouvriers agricoles et encore quand
il trouve une terre à cultiver ses nos
champs toutes nos plantations de
céréales sont perdus tout a été détruit
à cause des inondations
si l'inde ne connaît plus de famine
depuis la fin des années 60 elle est
loin très loin d'avoir gagné la bataille
contre la faim l'inde est donc la région
du monde la plus touchée par les
problèmes de malnutrition selon les
experts des nations unies 221 millions
de personnes souffrent de sous
alimentation
et pendant que le sommet se poursuit à
rome des spécialistes de l'institut de
recherche agronomique réunis à paris
rompant avec le catastrophisme ambiant
ont estimé que l'agriculture mondiale
pourra nourrir les milliards d'habitants
de la planète dans les décennies à venir
en raison d'une productivité accrue et
sous la condition d'une meilleure
répartition aux états unis cette fois
c'est la fin des primaires démocrates
les bureaux de vote ont ouvert dans le
dakota du sud et le montana les deux
derniers états à se prononcer barack
obama est favori dans les deux cas et il
se dit là bas qu hillary clinton
pourrait reconnaître sa victoire dans
les prochaines heures ou les prochains
jours
toujours aux etats-unis le virage d'un
géant mondial de l'automobile general
motors annonce sa conversion à la petite
voiture plus écologique
les ventes de gros modèles et notamment
les 4 4 se sont effondrés ces derniers
mois c'est la fin d'une époque
alain de chalvron aaron heilman sur
place à washington elles peuplent encore
les rues des grandes villes américaines
ces grosses quatre cadres en vérité
elles sont de plus en plus souvent en
stationnement mettre le contact et c'est
un litre d'essence qui s'envolent des
goinfres c'est bête elle flirte avec les
30 litres aux cent ça allait avec
carburant bon marché aujourd'hui avec le
litre à 75 centimes d'euros un prix
insupportables ici elles deviennent
avant
abl et s'entassent dans les parkings des
concessionnaires les affaires sont en
chute libre
peut-être 75 % de baisse sur les gros 4
4 par rapport à l'année dernière et
c'est compréhensible lorsqu'on en arrive
à dépenser 100 $ par semaine à la porte
on commence à se poser des questions sur
la taille de sa voiture d'où cette
décision drastique de la direction de
general motors fermeture de quatre
usines fabriquant ses subordonnés autres
pick-up et en même temps priorité aux
voitures vertes ne pensons que le déclin
de la demande pour ses 4,4 et durable et
nous avons connu des succès dans le
domaine des véhicules à propulsion
alternative
gm a déjà présenté des véhicules
hybrides des voitures à hydrogène ou
éthanol mais sans trop y croire on met
désormais les bouchées doubles dans ce
laboratoire national des centaines de
chercheurs venus du monde entier met au
point le véhicule du futur
les recherches seront tous azimuts mais
c'est déjà clair la voiture de demain ou
plutôt d'après demain sera à hydrogène
objectifs stratégiques de general motors
et en europe le carburant cher continue
à provoquer la contestation nouvelle
action des routiers agriculteurs taxi et
pêcheurs aujourd'hui avec en particulier
cette opération escargot qui a entraîné
d'énormes bouchons ce matin dans la
région parisienne entre gennevilliers et
la défense le périphérique notamment été
bloqués à noter qu'en espagne plus
grosse flotte d'europe les patrons
pêcheurs maintien de leur grève
illimitée
tout comme au portugal économie encore
en plein débat sur les 35 heures des
ouvriers de l'usiné bosch de beauvais se
disent prêts à renoncer à leurs jours de
rtt pour sauver leur site menacé de
fermeture
il propose aussi eux mêmes un gel des
salaires pendant deux ans sur place
fabien shadow frédéric bonne ils sont
prêts à remuer ciel et terre pour sauver
leur usine
le couperet est tombé il ya cinq jours
depuis ils bloquent le site
aujourd'hui on nous dit ben voilà ça y
est les usines fermées a donc on se bat
autour du piquet de grève ont retourné
le problème dans tous les sens pour que
la direction revienne sur sa décision
certains sont prêts à faire
d'importantes concessions avant de
défiler dans les rues de vauvert les
salariés ont fait une proposition pour
éviter la fermeture ils sont prêts à
renoncer à leurs 12 jours de rtt mais
certains posent leurs conditions si on
garde notre emploi pendant plus
longtemps encore si nous promettons
moins-disant emplois sur d'accord il ya
quatre ans les salariés de bosch à
vénissieux avait accepté de travailler
plus pour garder leur emploi
aujourd'hui le site à éviter la
fermeture et lorsqu'on en a plus de
travail est bien là la réduction de
temps de travail elle commence le matin
de bonne heure ça dure toute la journée
et ça dure jusqu'au soir qu'on se couche
donc je pense que entre avoir une perdre
quelques jours de rtt perdre son travail
c'est vraiment au salarié d'apprécier la
situation la direction dira demain matin
si elle accepte ou non de renoncer à la
fermeture de l'usiné de beauvais
l'assemblée nationale a commencé
l'examen de la fameuse aile m e la loi
de modernisation économique elle prévoit
entre autres de faciliter l'implantation
des grandes surfaces pour limiter la
hausse des prix on en a souvent parlé
mais la question divise le résultat et
il garantit autrement dit la
multiplication des hypermarchés ou des
supermarchés est elle vraiment une
assurance contre l'inflation grandes
surfaces le débat avec les incas et jean
francois monier plus de supermarchés
pour plus de concurrence et des prix
plus bas
pourquoi pas après tout en europe les
niveaux de prix varient tout comme le
nombre de grandes surfaces implantées
la france compte un peu plus de quatorze
supermarché pour 100000 habitants et le
niveau de prix et 5 points plus élevés
que la moyenne européenne
l'espagne elle compte plus de grandes
surfaces et ces prix sont nettement
inférieurs mais en suède où il y a
beaucoup
plus de supermarchés au contraire les
prix sont beaucoup plus élevés chaque
pays a donc ses spécificités
alors chez nous avec plus de grandes
surfaces les prix baissent vont-ils bah
oui s'il ya plus de magasins il ya plus
de concurrence et donc c'est bon pour le
consommateur
quand un nouveau magasin s'installe il
essaye de prendre des parts de marché
donc il veut avoir une offre très
attractive
donc il étire le client et notamment
avec des prix bien sûr que non parce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui que le territoire
est maillé il ya six grands groupes de
distribution qui contrôle il ya des
villes où tous ces groupes sont
représentés pour autant les prix sont
extrêmement chères en vérité on voit
bien qu'ils ne se mène pas une lutte à
mort on sait très bien que finalement
les prix sont pratiquement les mêmes
partout avec plus de grandes surfaces
quelles seront les conséquences
économiques
dire qu'on va renforcer le pouvoir des
grands distributeurs qui terme on va
exercer une pression encore plus forte
sur les fournisseurs les fournisseurs
pour continuer à exister vont devoir
comprimer leurs coûts de production donc
essayer de comprimer les masses
salariales peut être délocalisés
peut-être avoir recours à une sous
traitance dans des pays où la vie est
moins chère
il faut sortir de cette vision très
caricaturale des choses d'abord la
moitié de nos fournisseurs
ce sont des grands groupes
internationaux dont le il ya aucun
danger qu'ils soient prêts sur et la loi
d'ailleurs ne changera pas pour le reste
ce sont des pme avec qui nous
travaillons beaucoup par exemple 85% nos
marques de distributeurs sont produites
par des pme est plus dur à deux surfaces
plus on pourra exposer les produits des
pme si la loi est votée
le secrétariat d'état à la consommation
assure que l'augmentation du nombre de
grandes surfaces fera baisser les prix
de 1,6 pour cent en trois ans à propos
de niveau de vie et de logement vous
souvenez peut-être de ce couple de sans
abri qui avait ému la france il ya
quelques temps parce qu'il vivait sous
une tente à quelques mètres du
périphérique parisien et dix ans ont
passé quatre ans dans le bruit et les
intempéries et bien l'histoire évolue
dans le bon sens ils s'en sont sortis
nous les avons retrouvés aujourd'hui
installée dans une maison en dur à la
campagne le récit d'une résurrection
c'est le dossier de cette édition
il est signée jenny briffa thomas donzel
à 380 km de paris et de son périphérique
ils ont trouvé leur maison du
leurs 60 mètres carrés que gilles martin
et sa compagne ancien sdf retape ce jour
là ils ont fait appel au plombier du
village et à son épouse pour une fuite
dans la salle de bain ce petit souci
leur rappelle surtout que désormais ils
ont un logement bernal vous êtes heureux
bah ouais les gens quand on est venu
visite de l'usiné la maison je voulais
plus partir
pourtant on en a vu des maisons sur les
bouquets monoplace en direct pendant
quatre ans à paris ils ont vécu sous des
tentes
à l'époque il a accepté de témoigner
face aux caméras tous deux s'étaient
retrouvés à la rue suite à une
séparation
tous sommes dit s'était construit ce
petit abri de fortune
on les plus longs
les jeux et les lèvres dans la machine à
laver on a là un classique est une
télévision magnétoscope biscuits yumol 7
4 murs un doigt l'an dernier seconde
étape le couple et relogés
temporairement dans un village de mobile
homes pour exclu et puis il ya dix jours
ils ont emménagé dans leur propre maison
marie l'a payé grâce à la vente d'un
appartement acheté dans une autre vie
avec son ex mari pendant des longues
années gp comme un mets impôts j'ai fait
comme tout le monde
si je me suis retrouvé dehors c'est
parce que c'était en manque de travail
pendant 15 ans marie était gardienne
d'immeuble gilles paysagiste dans leur
nouveau village peu connaissent leur
histoire alors quand j'ai un sort son
album du périph comme il dit le plombier
et son épouse sont médusés
la deuxième année on était la bande à
lui moins 13 comme ça fait une pub et le
froid en europe et ce en tout ils
étaient quatre 4 ans
moi j'ai 10 ans drummond et bien ça
c'est bien le voir passer le pas le cas
poids savez nous on vit là on envie il
ya quatre cinq maisons quand vous prenez
les seuls habitants c'est bien que les
gens qui viennent habiter il ya des
maisons qui sont les lacets que des
maisons de campagne aussi la leur leur a
coûté 46 mille euros
puis entend les bruits des vaches là
c'est bien mieux qu'à entendre les
voitures ou les gens seuls gunilla bon
malgré son entorse
gilles tient à nous montrer son lopin de
terre 500 m² de quoi compléter le rmi de
ce couple sans emploi à voir mettre des
légumes faut faire les marchés allaient
un peu tout carottes poireaux pommes de
terre sellerie sahara qui se réalise
faut avoir la foi voire une grande
gueule pour les sur les marchés moi j'ai
une grande gueule alors ça va bien
désormais gilles et marie vont enfin
s'occuper de ce qu'ils ont négligé
depuis 10 ans leur santé la politique un
incident en vif à l'assemblée nationale
autour de la sphère du mariage de lille
a annulé pour défaut de virginité
interrogé par les bancs socialistes la
garde des sceaux rachida dati sous les
huées s'en est vivement prise à la
gauche mettant en cause la politique
d'intégration menées ces dernières
années et évoquant ce qui est rare son
cas personnel on les écoute
oui selon robbie ces décisions
difficiles à protéger cette jeune femme
ce qui vous dérange
où étiez vous lorsque vous avez créé la
politique des grands frères temps vous
avez abandonné
deux jeunes filles dans ces quartiers
difficiles entre les mains des grands
frères
la politique des grands frères c'est
vous c'est vous qui avez abandonné
votre politique d'intégration a été un
échec
alors vous pouvez attaquer la garde des
sceaux toulouse est matraqué comme bruit
en forme ce héros vous pouvez m'attaquez
mais j'ai échappé à l'échec de votre
politique qu'est ce qui vous dérange
alors s'il vous plaît
° n'empêchez pas ces jeunes filles
d'être libre une intervention qui on l'a
vu et entendu a provoqué de vives
protestations dans les rangs socialistes
toujours à l'assemblée les députés ont
adopté en première lecture la réforme
des institutions la gauche a voté contre
ainsi que 13 députés ump le sénat puis
le congrès doivent maintenant se
prononcer à la majorité des trois
cinquièmes pour ce dernier ce qui n'est
donc pas gagné le texte rappelons le
renforce les pouvoirs du parlement
autres dispositions remarquer il inscrit
les langues régionales dans la
constitution une reconnaissance de plus
pour ces langues et qui connaissent un
retour en grâce dans la région de
perpignan reportage antoine gaveau david
bres ne passeront pas coutume c'est une
prise de parole peu banal le 7 mai
dernier à l'assemblée nationale et pour
finir sur une auto d'humour madame la
ministre
suniula ministre elle catalan sous jane
hors ue ce daniel mach député des
pyrénées orientales clos son discours en
catalan cela fait rire la ministre mais
pas vraiment le président de séance
c'est vrai madame la main les catalanes
zumba de catalan dans l'hémicycle et
pourtant les députés veulent inscrire
les langues régionales dans la
constitution du basque aux créoles du
corso picard il en existe 75 elle
devrait bientôt être reconnue comme
patrimoine de la nation
un patrimoine qui a d'ailleurs déjà
beaucoup de succès à prades petite ville
au pied des pyrénées les plaques sont
bilingues et l'école aussi la preuve
bundy indique luca il parle català dans
cette classe de cm2 les élèves ont la
moitié des cours en catalan l'autre
moitié en français c'est comme ça depuis
la maternelle l'enseignement est
proposée jusqu'au lycée et apparemment
tout le monde trouve ça bien déjà si on
veut parler aux personnes âgées qui
parle catalan coût 10 comme ça c'est
bien on peut se dire des secrets entre
nous
nous adressent toutes les langues
régionales ont d'ailleurs le vent en
poupe à l'école l'alsacien est a pris
par 164 1000 élèves l'occitan par 80
milles le corse 35000 et le nombre
d'enfants qui les pratiquent a bondi de
60% en six ans pour dire dans l'article
une constitution appartient au
patrimoine le reconnaître la firme y
peut qu'asseoir montrer que l'école de
la république a eu raison de reconnaître
ce dispositif là l'amendement doit aussi
permettre une plus large diffusion des
langues régionales même si la télé
publique ne l'a pas attendu pour le
faire
france 3 sud diffuse par exemple chaque
dimanche du orale país une émission en
occitan et catalan elle existe depuis 83
et réunit plus de 45000 téléspectateurs
les chiffres du bac 2008 voici le plus
attendu
615 1625 candidats un chiffre en baisse
de près de 20% par rapport à l'an
dernier
le doyen de ce bac à 63 ans et voici
l'un des benjamins
il vient d'avoir 14 ans il est en
terminale s il a sauté quatre classes à
angers nabila taboury arnaud buste il
aurait dû être en classe de quatrième au
milieu d'adultes son âge il est au lycée
avec des camarades presque adultes 1
j'ai 14 ans je suis rangé son psg passe
son bac cette année lg 80 ans osel de ma
classe 18 ans avec un qi de 144 quand la
moyenne tourne autour de 100 sacha est
un enfant précoce au cours de sa
scolarité il a sauté quatre classes pour
autant il n'est pas sage comme une image
de newton ça
il est même plutôt turbulences et son
prof de physique qui le dit
ce tour sur sa chaise d'un côté de
l'autre il discute avec les voisins qui
sont derrière ou devant
non mais il aime bien faire rire le
monde
il s'agit je le reconnais je sais voilà
vous devez travailler le soir par ces
domaines si sacha décroche son bac c 4
en avance risque d'être un obstacle trop
jeune pour aller en prépa trop jeune
pour partir étudier à l'étranger
sacha lui retient surtout qu'il a du
temps devant lui nous devenir la
prochaine faire une fac de bio après
dans le futur j'ai le temps pour
réfléchir ça j'ai pas encore d'idée de
métier précise le père de sasha et
principal de collège
sa mère ancienne prof d'économie gérer
la précocité de leur fils et son
parcours scolaire n'a pas desserré
parents comme enfants mais ils ont
toujours réussi à composer avec la
différence de leurs enfants
on a tendance à oublier qu'elle est là
réellement ça c'est un autre rapport au
temps qu on assimiler et le 14 ans on
n'y pense pas souvent
voilà c'est quelqu'un qui va avoir son
bac qui croquent la vie et qui vend 30
versité on le prend comme ça
et même si ça chamakh au 11 de moyenne
générale ses parents sont persuadés
qu'il décrochera son bac dans les
moments importants avant sacha a
toujours su faire la différence
les intempéries la france n'est pas la
seule touchée en europe par ce printemps
très orageux vous l'avez peut être
constaté des trombes d'eau ont fait
trois morts ces dernières heures en
allemagne
claude santerre
ces images ont été tournées par un
habitant de la petite ville de yulin
guen dans le sud ouest de l'allemagne
peu avant 19 heures hier soir un violent
orage et des plus torrentielles
en quelques minutes la ville est envahie
par des torrents d'eau les habitants
tentent de sauver ce qu'ils peuvent mais
l'orage redouble de violence
en début de soirée les secours affluent
dans plusieurs villes et villages de la
région de randonneurs la situation se
complique je suis rentré dans mon
travail l'orage a éclaté et ma voiture a
été emportée par les flots
toute la nuit des centaines de
secouristes ont fouillé une à une les
voitures accidentées
trois personnes ont trouvé la mort ce
matin les petites villes des lieux
gilgen aider shingen s'efforcer de
retrouver un visage normal mais la tâche
est immense
les dégâts se chiffrent à plusieurs
millions d'euros
l'environnement alerte à la maladie
des palmiers de la côte d'azur aux
jardins du vatican les arbres sont
massivement touchés par un insecte
ravageur en sicile la contre offensive
est lancée par des chercheurs par des
agronomes
reportage à palerme karine comazzi
karine guillaume à palerme
c'est l'arbre symbole de la ville pas un
jardin pas une ville à 100 ses palmiers
majestueux un vieux prince de
méditerranée condamné par la maladie
dans ce par plus de la moitié des arbres
sont malades et dix d'entre eux ont déjà
été abattus ce sont très tristes parce
que c'est vraiment une plante magnifique
c'est dommage
j'espère qu'on va l'éradiquer cette
bestiole en des wendel telle qu'on la
voit là la secte est arrivé d'égypte en
italie à l'intérieur d'un arbre importer
une fois adultes ils volent et
contaminent les arbres voisins détecté
il ya trois ans sur la péninsule puis
l'an dernier à palerme il a déjà décimé
des dizaines de milliers de palmiers
inquiet de voir disparaître son
patrimoine naturel
ce botaniste tente de diagnostiquer le
mal avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
la base de la feuille à l'air d'être
abîmés voire c'est une galerie creusée
dans l'arbre par l'insecte
là les larves ont déjà fait un sacré
travail à l'intérieur du palmier c'est
un dessin en cinq mois du diagnostic
préventif le botaniste a réussi à
traiter attend près de 90 pamiers par
milieu des arbres centenaires mais c'est
une course contre la montre et contre
l'insecte qui a déjà gagné une grande
partie de la méditerranée
il ya urgence il faut absolument réagir
vite et maintenant en continuant les
abattages en soignant les arbres et si
possible en capturant les insectes avec
des pièges en attendant de trouver un
remède le gouvernement italien a décidé
d'interdire l'importation de pamiers
étrangers mais le panier italien un coût
de 500 à 5000 euros
à ce prix-là de carte postale est-ce que
d'appartenir au passé
revoilà etienne daho sept mois après la
sortie de son album qui lui a valu une
victoire de la musique
il est en tournée un peu partout en
france reportage christophe airaud il y
ait des rentes
et tient des ans de tourner jamais très
longtemps le dos à son public
et quand il joue au chef de choeur c'est
bien cette formation propose publiques
et les grandes qui se joue entre la
scène et la salle
demant l'adresse non plus pas toujours
facile pour lui a toujours sa team pour
tout le monde
beaucoup ont touché parfaitement la
danse parce que ça m'aurait solution
d'attenté
et à la scène comme il a la vie et
inversement puis il a changé ma vie
grâce à lui j'ai rencontré mon mari j'ai
rencontré deux années il a changé ma vie
la vie d'artiste etienne daho dure
depuis plus de 25 ans 9 albums des
mélodies pop à la voie en fruits dans la
musique dès qu'tu mélancolique des
récits intimes et parfois amusé cet
éternel jeune homme de la chanson dit
avoir réussi à garder le cas
se casser la gueule ça fait partie du
parcours un parcours justement c'est ce
à quoi parcours ne peut pas être
exponentielle tout le temps c'est pas du
tout intéressant un parcours est fait de
doute 2 2 d'accidents de désamour de
retrouvailles olivier jacque traite
exclusivement au festin qui fait les
langues
le soir l'ailier pierre met en place je
me lasse très vite des endroits j'ai
vraiment que je bouge ton est donc c'est
pour ça que la ville tournait me
convient justement très bien que ce sac
dans grâce à ça
cette journée est une invitation titres
de son dernier album une invitation au
voyage pour et avec etienne daho
et vous pouvez retrouver l'intégralité
de cet entretien sur la page 20 heures
du site france2 point fr en bref l image
du théâtre des folies bergères hier soir
où étaient réunis quelques 1200
professionnels du spectacle et de
l'audiovisuel inquiets face à la réforme
du financement de la télévision publique
à des artistes se sont relayés sur scène
pour apporter leur soutien au groupe
france télévisions qui consacre
rappelons le 360 millions d'euros par an
à la création artistique audiovisuel
images signées frédérick basile un mode
roland garros
on connaît la fiche de la première demi
finale elle opposera rafael nadal qui
s'est facilement imposé face à son
compatriote almagro en trois sets
voici la balle de match à djokovic qui a
battu plus difficilement le letton
gulbis
ce sera donc le numéro deux mondial
contre le numéro trois côtés et femmes
djokovic et ivanovic sont qualifiés pour
la première demi-finale
et puis une image vous le voyez de gaël
monfils toujours en course en simple qui
jouait aujourd'hui en double mixte avec
sa campagne la slovaque cibulkova
eh bien ils se sont inclinés 6-2 6-3
face à une paire serbe aux slovènes gaël
monfils sur tous les fronts il joue à
deux mains et ce sera à suivre bien sûr
sur france télévision en direct avant de
refermer ce journal je vous en rappelle
l'un des principaux titres
l'enquète sur la collision en haute
savoie le chauffeur du car scolaire
placée en garde à vue et interrogé par
la police depuis la fin de la matinée sa
version ne coïnciderait pas avec celle
des premiers témoins selon laquelle il
serait passé au feu rouge
une marche silencieuse s'est par
ailleurs déroulé à tonneau en hommage
aux sept collégiens suis c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi je
suit la météo laurent romejko 20h50 un
téléfilm retrouver sarah à demain
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr